bon allez quand les colas
[Musique]
la vie un petit nez sous sadate nba
ats
[Musique]
classement
donc
[Musique]
c'est une dramatique comme celles ci
sont presque normale sur le combat chez
à mumbai en au fil des ans
le pont est devenu l'un des principaux
sites de suicides et tentatives de
suicide dans la ville et la police n'a
pas réussi à ralentir cette tendance ce
sont généralement les pêcheurs locaux
qui plonge sauver des vies
lassana diarra mme joshi a accepté de
montrer à bruts ce qu'il faut faire pour
être un secouriste officiel élaboré le
pont bachir limoux bail à la ville
voisine la vie mbaye
c'est là que héros d'un grand succès de
bollywood sortie en 2013
haché qui d'eux a sauté pour mourir à la
fin du film
il semble avoir donné un sinistre
exemple
une petite ville qui servent achigan se
cache à quelques centaines de mètres du
plan les habitants comme rajar entrevue
la réputation de la ville changer au fil
des ans
[Musique]
des motos
et la montre
[Musique]
[Rires]
les appels de sauvetage demandée
autrefois beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
à rabat
mais pendant de nombreuses années il a
caché cette activité dangereuse à sa
femme et à ses jeunes
oudéa
[Musique]
il est 7 heures du matin
il n'y a pas encore eu d'appel mais il
est impossible de savoir ce que la
journée nous réserve
on attend
[Musique]
les pleurs
mon dan carter
salle au guatemala
combien de temps
alors que bateau de rajar dispose du
minimum de matériel nécessaire pour
sauver la vie précaire
les pompiers de vaches y sont équipés
d'un camouflage
des leviers mois d'octobre égard
les pompiers participent au sauvetage
mais ils soutiennent que les pêcheurs
sont parfois nous adapter pour ce
travail
[Musique]
non
malgré leurs efforts et leur
collaboration avec les autorités les
pêcheurs ne sont pas payés pour leurs
services
radja ram a donc dû trouver d'autres
moyens de joindre les deux bouts de
[Musique]
nombreuses années de sauvetage ont
laissé des traces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lamy
nationaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]